pour les employés fédéraux. Est-
ce que ça touche vraiment
beaucoup de monde?
- On a un plan qu'on a lancé
pour montrer comment on peut
défendre les droit des
travailleurs et travailleuses.
- Jagmeet Singh veut entre
autres faire passer le salaire
minimum fédéral à 20 $ l'heure.
Est-ce que ça toucherait
un grand nombre de Canadiens?
La réponse est non.
Les travailleurs qui sont régis
par le Code canadien du travail,
dans les banques,
le secteur aérien ou
les télécommunications,
par exemple, sont somme toute
peu nombreux. Ils représentent
8 % de la main-d'oeuvre au pays.
En décembre prochain,
le salaire minimum fédéral va
passer à 15 $ l'heure.
Ça permettra seulement
à 26 000 personnes d'avoir
une augmentation de salaire.
Combien seraient touchés
s'il passe à 20 $ l'heure?
On n'a pas la réponse exacte.
Mais selon les dernières
données de 2015, les trois
quarts des employés assujettis
aux normes fédérales gagnaient
déjà plus de 20 $ l'heure
dans le secteur privé.
Pour Jagmeet Singh, augmenter
le salaire minimum fédéral,
c'est une façon de montrer
l'exemple.
1 travailleur sur 10 gagne
le salaire minimum au pays,
mais la vaste majorité d'entre
eux sont sous réglementation
provinciale et travaillent
par exemple dans le commerce
au détail et la restauration.
C'est au Nunavut que le salaire
minimum est le plus élevé
au pays, à 16 $ l'heure.
Et parmi les provinces,
c'est en Colombie-Britannique,
à 15,20 $. Il est de 14,25
en Ontario, 13,50 au Québec
et le salaire minimum le plus
faible est en Saskatchewan,
à 11,45 $.
Sur cet enjeu, c'est davantage
les provinces qui peuvent
changer les chos